today alternative views will interview
Pete Bruton concerning his book the
Mafia CIA and George Bush Pete is a
former Houston Post reporter who broke
the story of the connections between the
S&L scandal and the CIA exposing how CIA
assets would borrow money from the SNL's
to finance off the book operations and
then declare bankruptcy and leave us
taxpayers with the bill well for the
past five years Pete has been tracking
down who actually profited from the SNL
scam who the main players were and how
they skimmed off their money lo and
behold he discovered that the
beneficiaries of the SNL scandals were
Friends of George Bush and his family
unsavory folks connected to the CIA and
mafia as well as associates of Texas
bigshot such as senator Lloyd Bentsen
and Houston power broker Walter Mischer
well obviously this is an explosive
story and today we are going to explore
the full ramifications of the SNL crisis
with author Pete Bruton who's now a law
student here at the University of Texas
Pete this is such an incredible story
one that is so complex it seems to me
almost one impossible to tell but you do
it so well in your book before we get
into the intricacies of it I wonder if
you can tell us how George Bush himself
was involved in this his family was but
was he himself involvement Bush's role
was on many levels first of all as vice
president during the Reagan Bush years
he was the head of the Reagan Bush
deregulation efforts across the board
and that included savings alone and the
deregulation of savings and loans that
occurred primarily in 1982 with the st.
germain Garn bill basically opened up
savings and loans to the crooks SNL's
had traditionally just done home
mortgage lending to middle-class
Americans and they succeeded very well
for 50 years they had some problems then
in the late seventies and early eighties
with the inflation
so the British Reagan Bush
administration and Congress decided that
they were going to deregulate
quote-unquote savings and loans and this
allowed SMEs to basically invest their
money and lend their money on anything
they wanted to and was an open
invitation to the criminal element and
sure enough the Mafia was one of the
first people groups involved in looting
SNL's in the early 80s and the
deregulation that bush was in charge of
did that Bush also his vice president
either he or his top aides intervened in
the federal regulation of the biggest
fail savings alone in the country at
that time
sunrise savings in Boynton Beach Florida
the CEO of sunrise went up to Bush his
office when he was vice president and
the story very he tells one story one
time in one story another either met
with bush with Bush's top aides included
C Boyden gray who is the current White
House Counsel and he asked them to get
the federal regulators off his back they
were trying to stop sunrise from
basically throwing their assets away and
one week after he met with these people
the Federal Home Loan Bank board that
regulates savings and loans withdrew a
very stringent cease and desist order
against sunrise and replaced it with a
weak supervisory agreement and a
congressional study found that this move
cost taxpayers possibly 100 million
dollars or more in keeping sunrise open
sunrise was then closed down a year
later year and a half later at a cost of
the federal taxpayers of seven hundred
million dollars and there was no Federal
Home Loan Bank board investigation it
was just shut down we find if you look
at the major borrowers that sunrise you
find mafia people you find CIA people
and you find a Houston businessman named
John riddle who he ties into the circle
of Houston businessmen that George Bush
come from and Riddle at this time was
involved in a transshipment of arms to
the Middle East now
top number two official at the Federal
Home Loan Bank board and Fairbanks was
in this meeting with the sunrise CEO
when he was asking them to get the feds
off his back her husband Richard
Fairbanks was in charge at that time
with the State Department's efforts to
keep arms from Iran called Operation
stunt he quit a year later and became
the Washington lawyer and lobbyist for
Iraq and worked with Iraq until Iraq
invaded Kuwait now it's interesting also
to note that the largest failed S&L in
the country that did not have a Federal
Home Loan Bank board investigation
sunrise was number two largest the
largest was hill financial in Red Hill
Pennsylvania that plays a big part in my
book and the number two borrower Hill
Financial was John riddles buddy
a Houston builder named Ike Atkinson who
at that time was transshipping arms to
the Middle East so he found a connecting
thread here of arms to the Middle East
and savings and loans and Bush's office
was directly involved in keeping this
sunrise sunrise say open and was lending
money to John riddle it seems like such
a complex thing but it seemed everywhere
you look there are certain things going
on the CIA and the Mafia and there were
drugs that were being run back into the
United States there were illegal arms
being procured and sent to the Contras
as well as to Iran and Iraq as we know
and Iraq but all of these interests
coincided the Mafia they how did the
Mafia with the Mafia just after money is
that how and and perhaps the selling of
drugs when they came back into the
United States
I think the Mafia just found it is
another you know trough they could feed
it and I think they were in on it at the
beginning when they saw they knew a
deregulation was going to do and the
fact that they they figured out a scheme
and then the head of this scheme was a
York mobster named Mario Renda who went
to jail for like less than three years
he was convicted new york florida in
kansas city Orenda would collect money
from various institutions like pitch and
funds and credit unions bundle it up and
$100,000 bundle so it was covered by
Federal Deposit Insurance and then place
it in savings loans all across the
country billions of dollars and once he
got the money the deposits into an SNL
he could basically control them he could
he had a hammer over their head if they
didn't do with this money what he wanted
he'd just pull it out and this was
called linked financing he would place
the deposits and then tell the SNL's to
loan the money to lend the money to his
buddies they would then just rip it off
take it in and rip it off now in Texas
we found a Louisiana mobster named
Herman KBB who was controlling SNL's in
a different way than Renda and we found
BB and Renda together in many many
different places across the country many
connections between the two but BB would
actually finance the purchase of savings
and loans by his associates like Don
Dixon and Vernon Carol Kelly at
Continental Jarrett woods at Western the
Roy Daly at first savings of East Texas
and then he would have a hammer over
their head where he was holding the note
on their stock to the S&L so they would
do what he wanted to I think it's so
significant what you've pointed out that
this isn't just something these
relationships are something which came
together suddenly when they said oh hey
here's a great big pig let's cut it up
there were this was just a continuation
of relationships between powerful people
at various levels of state local and
national that have been going on for
some time that's correct in fact we have
a sort of dry run on the S&L scandal in
the mid 70s in Texas with the so-called
Texas winter Bank scandal where we have
the same people that showed up in the
S&L crisis ripping off small Texas banks
and doing the same thing trading bad
loans between each other trading capital
stock loans between each other
herma KBB was in the middle of that
benbarnes is his business partner was in
the middle of it and then later Ben
Barnes and John Connally show up his big
big borrowers and many of the dirtiest
SNL's in the country
George Albin another guy that was
involved in savings and loans was in the
Texas renovating scandal so and the
federal government knew about the rent
of Mexican the king did and did an
investigation there was a Savings and
Loan in Texas in Houston called surety
that a woman named rosemary Stewart was
in charge of the federal regulation out
in Washington and she saw her McKay be
she saw Walter Misha
she saw mr. son-in-law Robert Corson and
when these people all got back in the
SNL's you know five ten years later she
did nothing and that she was then in
charge of the office of enforcement of
the Federal Home Loan Bank board Pete
yeah your book begins in fact by
discussing Walter Mischer who's a
Houston banker and power broker as a
major player in this whole SNL scam can
you tell a little bit about him and what
role he actually played in this scenario
yeah Walter Mischer was at the very
center of the Houston business
connections that all you take all these
SNL's you start tracking back where the
money goes and you find Mischer and his
friends Mischer was what we call a
hyphenated Texan banker hyphenated
developer and probably a few other
hyphens in there too
political power broker he controlled
politicians on all levels measure
basically told the Houston developers
who they were going to donate political
campaign campaign money to measure had
the third largest bank in Houston allied
bank and he used allied bank to finance
many different things including some of
the dirtiest savings or loans in Houston
like Continental savings mainland
savings and some others and in fact
Mischer knew that the S&L were going
down the tubes in the early 80s because
he sold a savings and loan he had Ben
Franklin savings that at one time had
belonged to Lloyd Vincent's company he
also ordered all the SNL capital stock
loans out of allied in 8283 so that when
these SNL's failed he wouldn't be caught
holding the bag and in turn he had many
savings of loans
helping he and his bank out indirectly
and one kind of mainland savings in
Houston bought a 20 million dollar loan
that allied held on an oil company was
in bankruptcy and a later investigation
showed that mainland lost at least
fourteen million dollars on this there
was no hope of repaying and Leyland just
did as a favor to allied the CEO of
mainland had had his mainland stock
financed at allied bank it was a good
friend of all term assured and what sort
of political friends did Walter major
have who or his main for the political
connections well mister goes back to the
old 8 F days Ala Moana Hotel in Houston
where the Brown Brothers Jesse Jones Gus
were them these people were wheelin
dealin controlling Houston and
politicians like Lyndon Johnson it goes
back that four and then you bring a
measure was very close to John Connally
benbarnes
Lloyd Bentsen and George Bush and most
of the Houston mayors and Harris County
judges almost all of the Texas
governor's except for Ann Richards I'm
not sure about her but we know doc
Briscoe and
even Republicans like bill Clements
Misha was very close to and supported
Fischer's political donations and
influence went to both parties it was
not just Democrats for me he supported
Democrats of course back in the 50s and
60s when Democrats controlled this state
but he also you know controlled and
helped a lot of Republicans like John
tower and in George Bush and Bill
Clinton
so he was a well-connected fellow very
well-connected and not just of course
the politician he was connected to the
Mafia well that's why it was a big shock
I mean when I was reported Euston Post
and people started telling me about his
connections to the Mafia and we did a
big interview with him and it was on the
cover of the Houston post Sunday
magazine and I asked him what about all
the rumors about your connections to
carlos marcello the new orleans mafia
boss and he admitted that he'd sat down
to do business with marcelo at one time
Marcel would come in and wanted to buy a
couple of his hotels including the
carousel Hotel on the South Loop and he
said he did not sell them to him because
he did not want to get quote run out of
town well it turns out when you
investigate who he really sold it to
turns out to be a Marcello frontman and
associate so he really did in Mischer
and his partners kept the D the title to
this hotel while Marcello's frontman was
showing the x-rated movies and running
prostitutes in this hotel
and what about hkb be his connections
with Walter Mischer and the mob you know
will be the roar of the Louisiana mafia
associate from Shreveport had turned up
first in the Texas rental bank scandal
where he was connected to Ben Barnes who
of course was in Walter Bishop pocket BB
then was borrowing money from measures
allied bank
issue was supporting him there
operating loans giving him insurance
business and in one case the stock of
Continental savings in Houston was
financed that measures allied bank with
a guarantee from Herman KBB so they were
very close in doing business not only in
the text Houston area but in Louisiana
we find associates of Mischer very close
associates including the farmer
controller of the currency Robert Clark
going in and buying a bank with Herman
KBB in Louisiana along with to the two
top executives that measures bank now
was he was be be under marchello well
absolutely garden okay and this had been
determined actually by the Texas
Attorney General's organized crime
strike force in the mid 70s now John
Hill is actually had an organized crime
investigative unit headed by I believe
Tim James and they found the connections
between hurricane BB and carlos marcello
BB was also tied to marcelo by the New
Orleans Metropolitan Crime Commission
this is back in the mid seventies and
then you find all of the connections
then later with the SML scandal can you
give us an example of how they mafia
comes in with the mob Lutz savings alone
or two and then move on well it would
indeed ease case he would actually
finance the the controlling stock of an
SML and then the loans would be made to
either BB or his associates and then
they would take the money and walk to
loans and leaving the S&L with property
that wasn't worth any what their what
they'd Lin on it and that's the way they
basically failed how did the CIA get
involved in with these people well
that's a good question I don't think we
know the final answer yet there are some
people who believe that William Casey
had been in on the beginning of the
deregulation and knew that it was
susceptible you know Casey was an old
Wall Street lawyer and head of the SEC
at one time and knew that the the SNL's
are very
being looted and the money taken out and
never found but on the other hand we
have people like Walter Mischer who are
connected to the CIA can probably see
that if they keep the CIA happy you know
diverting some of the money to CIA
operations then you know they will get
what the FBI calls the CIA's
get-out-of-jail-free card in other words
if they're working doing and helping the
CIA and they get caught and the CIA can
come in and say don't prosecute this
person he's working with us and that
happened on a number of occasions in the
S&L crisis where we would have a Savings
and Loan looter or a bank looter getting
caught by the FBI and the Justice
Department the CIA trying to get them
off the hook because they work with them
now we've had on alternative views as if
you've been watching alternative views
regularly know that about the drug scams
which were going on where illegal arms
would be shipped down to the Contras
particularly and the c-130s would be
filled up with cocaine and all and
brought back in the United States and
offloaded sometimes at US Air Force
bases sometimes that more covert landing
strips now how would this operation fit
in with what we're talking about right
we found a number of people in Florida
they were helping the Contras taking
weapons guns for drugs that were
involved in failed banks and savings and
loans one CIA gun and drug runner wasn't
going to Jack DeVoe and DeVoe was
actually bringing in his cocaine into
the Ocean Reef Club on Key Largo it was
owned by
a lender the Cincinnati businessman and
it's very close to Bush very close to
Bush ok Bush would go down and actually
vacation at the Ocean Reef but there's a
picture in my book a bush and a fishing
boat off Ocean Reef this is where Jack
Duvall was bringing in his cocaine and
devote was also taking guns down to
Latin America for the CIA now des Vosges
money-launderer was a miami attorney
named Lawrence Freeman Freeman had
previously worked for Paul hello well
one of the founding fathers of the CIA
and also was laundering money for Santo
Trafficante the Tampa Florida mafia boss
Freeman drew up the documents the sales
contract for a 21 thousand acre land D
on the Florida Panhandle that he'll
financial savings the one in
Pennsylvania we preview talked about
envision bank savings in Kingsville
Texas that was on our altar measures
former son-in-law financed here we have
Lawrence Freeman drawing up the papers
and involved with these people and he's
you know closely connected the CIA had
been the in-house counsel for Cassell
Bank and Trust and NASA a bank that was
used by the Mafia in the CIA to hide and
launder money and was shut down when
Paul Helliwell died and appeared that
many of these these offshore money
laundering operations were moved after
Cassell bank failed in the shutdown to
the Isle of Jersey and Lawrence Freeman
was laundering Jack DeRose drug money
through the island Jersey
Robert Corson wishers former son-in-law
and McKagan sin' were laundering SNL
money through the island Jersey along
with some people in Colorado that
connect to Neil Bush all were using the
same the same trust the same trust in
the al Jersey we're getting drug money
and that's the nettle money and they
were mixed in in the same bank accounts
I'm P could you give some examples of
how the CIA would loot SNL's and what
they used the money for well it's not
like the CIA would you
get a loan from an S nailing down the
bottom line you know for guns guns to
the countries signed by the CIA right
that's not the way they operate I mean
they use cutouts and front people so
that to maintain their plausible
deniability so they can come in and deny
that it wasn't them and once it cut out
then a cut out is a front man a middle
person who may not even know he's
working for the CIA I think there could
be four or five levels of cutouts in
front me of the layers that the CIA
would the money would flow through so
that it couldn't be tracked back to the
CIA one of the best examples we have in
the SNL's was when mainland savings this
is the S&L that walter measure was
financing the stock of this is the SML
whose chair of the board raymond hill
was a close and long-time friend of
James a baker the third White House
chief of staff former Treasury secretary
former Secretary of State George Bush's
best friend when mainland failed
James Baker's old law firm Andrews and
Curt in Houston was brought in by the
feds to investigate the failure and file
a lawsuit against the officers and
directors to try to recover the lost
money Andrews and Corinth investigated
actually drew up a lawsuit a petition
but was never found it was stopped at
the top layers of Andrews Kirk and the
federal government and as a result no
lawsuit was ever filed against Raymond
Hill the mainland CEO and no money was
ever recovered no indictments have ever
been filed against anybody in the
failure of mainland savings okay so here
we have this that's now it's wired in to
walter measured and James Baker in the
summer of 1985 James Baker went before a
Senate Finance Committee as Treasury
secretary and told them that there was
nothing to worry about in the SNL's
everything was wonderful and fine and
nothing bad was going to happen at the
very same time mainland Savings was
entering into a sixty-eight million
dollar land deal with
non khashoggi a Saudi Arabian middleman
and arms dealer and it was a very
complicated deal the result of it was
that khashoggi walked away with about
sixteen million dollars in cash profit
pure profit from this land deal the
taxpayers later got stuck with about a
fifty million dollar loss on this deal
this was close this deal was closing the
money transferred on August the 1st 1985
six days later Adnan Khashoggi begins
the transfer of five million dollars to
kobani for the Iranian middlemen to
start the first publicized honours for
hostages deal it's interesting that he
transferred five million dollars to go
Bonaparte because at the same time
mainland was basically giving him
sixteen million dollars they also gave
him a five million dollar letter of
credit that was very strange because it
could only be drawn on the first week in
November of 85 and had all the earmarks
of the guarantee and in fact later when
Khashoggi x' people were trying to cover
this up from the FBI who caught on to
this pretty soon they said it was a to
guarantee some stock that Khashoggi had
bought from mainland but the money to
buy that stock had come from mainland to
steal no work mainland gave khashoggi
ten million dollars he gives it back to
the end of the exchange for ten million
dollars in stock and they said oh by the
way here's a letter of credit for five
million dollars to guarantee the stock
it didn't make any sense at all because
it came from mainland the money came
from mainland but the five million
dollars matches exactly the five million
dollars that khashoggi paid to mana for
Sookie this is in a sense the beginning
of iran-contra yes it's funded with SNL
money so one of the reasons why Baker
and bush and the US government was not
regulating the SNL's was not doing
something about this crisis that was
emerging is because they were using the
SNL's to finance some of their
off-the-book activities they didn't want
Congress or the public to look into
nothing's added correct I think that's
what happened now whether we can prove
that they quote used them you know we
probably never know but that is the
ultimate upshot of what happened and the
money of course from mainland ultimately
came from the American taxpayers so we
went in since we're financing these
covert illegal operations and it's the
way that of course all over north wind
case hits away George Bush the way they
like to do things
I mean North testified before Congress
at what William Casey was looking for
trying to set up was a self-sustaining
off-the-shelf self-financing covert
operation and here we had it we see it
in operation with the Savings and Loan
money that ultimately came from the
American taxpayer so you know Khashoggi
wasn't out any money the Iranians and
Israelis really weren't anybody came
from the American taxpayers in general
now in so much of what we've talked
about previously at alternative views
and in a lot of the news stories that
you would read they would mainly focus
on the savings and loans themselves and
all these wheelers and dealers like Don
Dixon up and burning savings or Charles
Keating and all that but we're talking
about a stratum above that those people
aren't we know definitely I think Dixon
and Keating and all the others ed
McBurney Jarrett woods tyrell barker
were just front men I mean they were cut
outs basically and if you look at how
much money they got I call him one or
two percenters Dixon got maybe what
twenty million dollars out of Vernon I
mean he himself and learning this
costing taxpayers over 1 billion dollars
Keating got about 40 million dollars and
Lincoln savings is costing taxpayers two
billion dollars so you can see you're
getting one or two percent and and it's
a classic front man set up and the
people that you get to who's really
getting this money and you start
scratching and digging you find that
you're in another stratum as you say a
businessman who are connected to the
politicians very strongly of course
Keating had strong connections to but if
you look at who got the
money out of Lincoln he's find John
Connolly and Ben Barnes getting close to
a hundred million dollars you find a
little bank in Paris called Saudi
European Paris taxes Paris no actually
Paris France Paris Frank yeah it
connects into the BCCI
Ojai State and Keating was investing
money in that and he starts scratching
today and he find even bigger players
than Keating finding this so then
there's that this layers the layer of
the Mafia and the CIA and was anybody
was there another layer above them like
the big banks they must they were
getting the money the benefits of the
money laundering from drugs because they
would be laundered through the u.s. big
banking system North Korea were they
also benefiting from this that even a
same level or higher level well the
banks and insurance companies believe it
or not were so the big institutions got
bailed out by the SNL's if you had a
piece of property or an office building
that the first mortgage of the first
lien on it
might be held by a big bank or big
insurance company and when the savings
and loan would come in and take out
everything and refinance the whole deal
the banks and SNL's would get paid off
by the savings of only fact that
happened in the khashoggi deal Texas
Commerce Bank at a 15 million dollar a
mortgage against cash oh geez property
and the money to pay off that mortgage
came from mainland savings and also
Lamar savings in Austin joined in in
that so Texas Commerce Bank got all
their money back from the Savings and
Loan
do you find it happen time and time
again a piece of property will have a
first big first mortgage by a bank or
insurance company that will get paid off
by the S&L where they take the whole
deal out well as I understand the big
banks I mean the Wall Street banks and
all a lot of these deals a lot of the
property would be resold and eventually
they would come up into the hands of
these bigger banks and insurance
companies like in New York and so I
guess they would be the first ones to be
paid off in any type of bailout would
they not well sure I mean if they
the first mortgage they get they're
going to get the money first before
anybody the savings alone might be
holding a third or fourth mortgage I
mean they would wrap these things and
flip these things so that the S&L might
be third or fourth in line and would
never get once the property sold in the
first mortgage mortgage is paid off the
S&L is left with nothing
Pete there's a chapter of your book
called the mobsters spooks and George
Bush the Palmer National Bank story that
ties all these things that we're talking
about together in other words the way
that high-level officials with
connections for the government corporate
and political officials formed a bank
the Palmer National Bank and how it
became connected with all these unsavory
operations you want to give us some
detail on this to sort of concretely
illustrate this analysis empower
National Bank had just about everybody
in it was a small bank still exist in
Washington DC about two blocks north of
the White House it was started by a
Louisiana businessman named Harvey
McLean and a political operative from
Washington DC called Stephan Halper and
McClendon halper met in 1980 when they
were both working on George Bush's
presidential campaign and Halper later
was was head of the policy group for
Bush and then when Reagan became the
nominee and Bush was named vice
presidential candidate Halper went to
work for their campaign is part of the
policy group and was actually a
high-level official in what they called
the October Surprise group the group
that was trying to determine whether or
not Carter was going to pull off an
October Surprise and get the Iranian
hostages home or whatever might and
halper was was in charge of this group
his father-in-law was ray client who was
the former deputy director of
intelligence of the CIA Klein was
working with them with Bush and then
when when Reagan and Bush wanted Halper
went to work for the State Department
they created a position for him and
James Baker by the way was the one that
brought help
over to the reagan-bush team after
Reagan became the nominee from the bush
team so and Harvey MacLean was a
businessman from Shreveport Louisiana
and he was being financed by none other
than Herman KBB the mafia associate
MacLean moves to Dallas and buys Perry
savings alone in Paris Texas and is
borrowing money from Vernon savings from
Continental savings in Houston and later
of course all these loans go bad and
Paris goes bust and MacLaine's business
deals cost taxpayers probably over a
hundred million dollars that's kind of
getting ahead of the story back in 83
MacLean and I were taking a trip to
China and they start talking about let's
get a bank in Washington DC so they they
start Palmer National Bank Palmer was
named after MacLaine's grandmother and
daughter and the capital the $3,000,000
capital to start the bank came from
Hermann kbv and Bossier Bank and Trust
Dean I connected to the mob in Louisiana
and into the ends everywhere and the
mission and Ben Barnes John Connolly all
these people
so when soon as they started this bank
they began lending money to conservative
Republican PACs like Bob Dole and Jack
Kim and then they take on another client
the national endowment for the
preservation of Liberty which was
started by Oliver North and a guy named
Spitz channel to funnel private
donations to the Contras okay and of
course the biggest donor was Ellen
Garwood here in Austin the widow of the
former Supreme Court justice and Palmer
National Bank was also lending money to
the national endowment for operating
loans and for furniture loans and
helping funnel the money that's where
the head of the bank would the money
would go from Palmer National Bank to
another Washington bank to the Cayman
Islands and it over to Geneva
Switzerland in in the bank account
it credits with where not only was
contra money being flowed into but
Iranian arms profits were all seaboard
was operating that was that was C courts
and then then it would go out to the
Contras and Palmer was that was the
starting point of the money and Palmer
National Bank also made a loan on a a
beach house in Solana Beach California
that BB and Dixon would use to entertain
SNL regulators including ll Bowman in
fact they mayor that's where he
allegedly had a tryst with a prostitute
in that beach house and power National
Bank had a piece of the action on that
beach house and later Stephane Halper
was when he got caught in a debate gate
scandal if you call that the theft of
the Carter debating manuals that ended
up in the Reagan Bush campaign it
apparently James Baker or William Casey
or both of them were involved in and
that was just part of an enormous covert
action against the Carter Administration
which they had something like hundred
and thirty seven operatives and all
kinds of high levels spying snooping and
even stealing top-secret documents and
this is just one of their will help
Parrish correct the helper was involved
in that and he course his name surfaced
in 1984 when this came out and he had to
sort of leave he kind of backed out of
Palmer National Bank but he stayed in
touch with these people of course and
then when Oliver North was fired by
Reagan in November of 1986 when the when
the scheme where they were you know
using profits from the Iranian arms
deals to fund the Contras and all came
tumbling out in Reagan fired North the
very last entry in Oliver North's White
House Diaries was legal defense firm -
Stefen Halper our old Palmer National
Bank Gunny who also again I want to make
this october surprise connection because
Halper was the head of the october
surprise committee for the reagan
election team in 1980 which was
frightened to death that
the Carter Administration was going to
negotiate the release of the hostages
which may be one of the reasons why they
stoled the debate book as well as did
these other covert actions against
Carter because they wanted to find out
what he was doing for this hostage
release and if possible subvert it and
give the Iranians a better deal at least
that's the account that Gary SiC and
others give that's correct we don't was
a little over and how it worked out that
way they rigged a deal so that the
Iranians would hold the hostages until
after the election and return for arms
and lo and behold 20 minutes after
Reagan raised his hand and said that he
would ruin the country the hostages were
released
well even and here we had this little
Bank you know that was involved in all
this being financed with Louisiana mafia
money and when Herman KBB was convicted
first convicted in 1985 of course they
moved that loan out of Bossier Bank to a
little savings alone in Beaumont Texas
called San Jacinto savings different
from San Jacinto and Houston and if you
look at the board members and that Bank
you find two people who were major
stockholders in the casinos Caesars
Casino in Las Vegas the course was was
being scammed by the Chicago mafia at
that time that's absolutely incredible
how all this is connected October
Surprise iran-contra SNL mafia CIA all
of it William Casey all of these
operations under the Reagan
administration were interconnected as
well as the players then you find the
same people in the same threads running
through these these operations and the
money you know from SNL's going into
these operations can you tell us another
story about a landing strip in La
heaters Texas yes I first found out
about the possible connections to the
savings of loans in the CIA and I guess
the fall of 1988 when a woman in Houston
called up my associate Houston post Greg
C and told him berated him about some of
our coverage of SNL's that weren't
getting the whole story so we went to
see her her name was Rebecca Simms
she had been Robert Corson Misha was
foreign son-in-law his accountant and
she had quit because he'd been asked to
commit bankruptcy and tax fraud and so
she started investigating Corson and she
found out that Corson had been a asset
of the CIA and when she first told me
that I really wasn't interested in it at
all I had no interest in it I wasn't
looking for the sea I was looking to the
Mafia and I guess I was even a little
disappointed but when I went back to my
office I remember several things one
when we had done the story on Walter
misharin had been calling everybody all
his people he knew just get background
information on him one of his close
associates told me about the 700,000
acres in beliefs and Central America he
was brought into and that his associate
thought that this was a CIA operation
and this was someone who's very close to
measure and would not say something like
that unless he knew it would had
something to and I sort of filed that
you know away in my mind I remembered
that came up and then I remember there
was a organized crime strike force
prosecutor in Kansas City that was
chasing Mario Renda the New York mob
money broker and I had been I was
chasing Renta - so we had a lot of
contact I've been sending him our
stories we've been writing in the
Houston post and he said almost the same
thing Rebecca Simms and said you're
missing something big here there's
something you're not getting and so I
wondered if he was talking about the CIA
so I flew up to Kansas City and and met
with him and sure enough that was it he
was talking about the CIA so that's how
the CIA connection rose and Rebecca
Simms had been told about the CIA
connection from a man named Richard
brenneke
oh my gosh he's his name pops up over
Exiles iran-contra drugs Ricky had been
the sort of renegade intelligence agent
in Portland Oregon he had received a lot
of notoriety because he some of the
breaking stories on iran-contra had come
from him on the Iranian arms deals and
some of the Contra arms deals and the
New York Times the Newsweek had used him
as a major source and so I went up to
see brenneke and I spent a week with him
and when I when I got back
I'd really didn't have much because
brenneke didn't have a lot of documents
backing up what he was saying it was
very frustrating experience with Brenna
Quixote's he's a typical kind of
intelligence agent that will will
deliberately lie to you on some
occasions I mean you just can't trust
everything he tells you but on the other
hand he will tell you the truth on a
number of cases and he at one point in
our conversations began describing and
landing strip in Far West Texas that had
been a CIA guns for drugs deal you know
guns and drugs transshipment point and
he said they flew c-130s and there is a
four thousand but so I I ripped a big
sheet of paper out of an illegal
notebook and I said draw me a map you
know she starts drawing this man but
here was lahee tiss which is west of big
ben easy go he said about ten miles
northeast and there's this mesa it had a
very detailed map four thousand V gave
me the the the way was oriented the fact
that there was a mountain just north of
it and there was a Mesa there and so I
took that back to Houston with me hoping
it on I didn't maybe this would check
out so I got a USGS class a topo map of
the area which I'm I was absolutely
positive would show a landing strip that
big four thousand feet and I get the map
out and look at it and I could see about
where it should have been according to
his his map and there was
on the map and so I said well I'll give
it one more shot or get the aerial
photographs that they use to make these
maps they take care of photographs and
so over the area of photographs and I
got them out and I looked at them and
there was right exactly what the landing
strip exactly ready described it and the
FAA had no record it wasn't on any map
and so I went out out to that to is
about 15 miles northeast levitus and
about let's say less than ten miles from
terlingua and actually drove out to it
and looked at it and began talking to
people about it and basically got it
confirmed that it was a c-130 s flew in
there with arms and drugs and and
brenneke had told me that when he flew
in there that he asked the people he was
flying in there with who were people by
the way associated with the Medellin
Cartel whose landing strip this was he
was told it was what they told him
Walter Mishra
now Misha owns at that time it owned
probably close to three hundred thousand
maybe more acres in that area but he
didn't own that piece of property
he had land to the west of it and land
to the south of it so when I began
researching who owned this property I
found a widow in Florida actually owned
that property and she had never been
there in her life and only found out a
few years before I talked to her that a
landing strip was there because one of
her relatives went hunting can told her
did you know there's a landing strip
Rhonda Miller your property and she said
no and that she said it was done without
her knowledge or permission and of
course there what a great it was
actually the only place in that era
that's a very rough rugged country there
just west of Big Bend it was the only
level place for miles and miles around
in that vicinity that you could put a
landing strip and of course if a widow
from Florida has never been there owns
it in just about anybody wanted to
probably could curse the law enforcement
had to know about it we talked to them
you get contradictory answers and
inconsistent answers and they're trying
to cover up obviously although they
would acknowledge that they've seen
c-130s in the vicinity there's no reason
to see one of course there is a
low-level training round c-130s out of
San Antonio in that area what it what a
perfect cover of course for flying in
c-130s can we got up to a higher level
of politics again mr. clean mr. Benson
Lloyd Bentsen he's connected with this
in some way yeah I'm ready to bid some
in a number of places the first place
Iranian Lloyd Bentsen was in Jefferson
savings which was in the Rio Grande
Valley I live in McAllen Jefferson
savings had been started by Lloyd
Bentsen and his brother in Benson's
father back in the mid-50s and they
controlled it up until the mid 70s when
they sold it to a man named Guillermo
Hernandez cart a lien Cartaya is one of
the really bad boys of the Western
Hemisphere
he's a Cuban exile fought in the Bay of
Pigs was a member of the infamous 2506
brigade had been involved in narcotics
trafficking money laundering gun-running
terrorist activities out of Florida with
a company called world finance the IRS
the FBI had close to 200 people
investigating world finance in the
mid-70s and all was ready to pop Cartaya
big when the CIA stopped them it came in
and basically had the the investigation
dismantled and as a result car tire was
just convicted on income tax charges at
that very same time he comes and buys
Jefferson savings from the Benson family
okay and proceeds to loot it and run
drug money through it when the Justice
Department came in to investigate car
Tahlia we brought in by the Texas
regulators an art eliezer who was the
chief S&L examiner for the state of
Texas brought in the feds
the CIA came down and met with the
prosecutor and asked him to back off
Cartaya because of all the favors
Cartaya had done for our government
including it turns out scamming about
thirty million dollars from the United
Arab Emirates bank with the parent
permission of the CIA in Cartaya that
the Justice Department did not back off
Cartaya on that deal he was convicted
but his sentence was rolled into his our
arrest sentence and I don't know how
many year you probably don't get a
couple years in jail the next year after
that happened car tire was again
indicted along with his partner camilla
padre de another Cuban exile in Miami
that indictment was stopped for some
reason the Justice Department said later
was flawed but just thought why they
draw it up camilla padre de shows up ten
years later as a partner of Jeb Bush the
president's son in Miami now when I
found out about Cartaya and also
Jefferson saves the fact Lord Benson had
you know own part of them I called up
Benson's office I asked him about it I
got his press secretary Jack Devore
asking my questions you know what was
Benson's role in this essay I am you
know what he owned did he know Cartaya
etcetera etcetera and divorce said he'd
get back to me that the senator was in
some conference on the Canary Islands
which is off the coast of Africa about
an hour later Devore calls me back and
said the senator never owned any stock
in this S&L doesn't know anything about
never anything to do with it
and so you sure about this she said yes
I satisfied myself he doesn't recall
owning anything and say well that's
funny
I got a document here from the SNL
Department that shows he owned sixteen
point seven percent of the original
stock and continued to own it up into
the 60s these these signatures are
notarized you said I'll get back to you
thirty minutes later I get a call from
Lloyd Bentsen himself from the Canary
Ellen's saying oh yes he had on stocking
that but he got out of it
the mid-segment and bought in Brazos
port savings which later became
Continental savings okay and then I
asking about car tires a new us and what
about the CIA interference he assured me
that hadn't happened because he would
have known about it
well in fact I got this story straight
from the prosecutor that the CIA went to
and so either Benson lied to Devore or
Devore lied to me there's no other
explanation for it I mean they somebody
lied I mean they told me a lie the dense
that had never been only stalking this
as now and if I hadn't had that document
they would have gotten away with the
line now it's interesting to note that
this SNL that Benson bought after he got
out of Jefferson became continent say
these and that purchase was financed by
Herman KBB so it's possible that mafia
money went to Lord Benson now when I
asked to lure about that he said they
didn't know the BD was financing killing
so it had no knowledge calculator got on
that whether mob meant this was my money
or not in fact it was well didn't Benson
also later and when he was running his
vice president didn't he put the kibosh
on any investigation or statements and
any of the debates about the SNL's and
that part of your book too
yes well you know in 1988 the country
knew we had an SNL problem we didn't
know the extent of it okay the the
original estimates had been something
like maybe 10 15 million dollars the
Republicans of course were Bush's the
candidate did not bring up the s you
know Benny Bush's son tenido was right
in the middle of Silverado savings which
was about to be taken down in fact was
taken down only a couple of weeks after
the presidential election someone in
Washington had called the regulators in
Topeka Kansas that regulated Silverado
and told them not to shut Silverado down
until after the presidential election
and that's in fact what happened on the
other side Benson was the
Democratic vice-presidential nominee he
went to the Dukakis campaign people and
told them not to bring up the S&L crisis
and so they did the democrats did not
use that as an issue they could have
pounded the republicans over the head
with it or maybe won the election in
haiti perhaps of course we had you know
we had the Keating five for the Keating
five were Democrats I mean the
Democratic Congress had just as much to
answer for
as a Republican administration and so
neither side wanted to bring it up of
course both sides were being paid off by
people like Mischer I mean they always
cover their bets the the people I
measure you know they support both sides
so regardless of who wins they've gotten
in and George Bush and Lloyd Bentsen are
part and parcel of the same small
Houston businessman circle they're all
term issues at the middle of Joe Russo
is part of in a guy named Jim bath a CIA
operative in Houston is good friends
with George Bush and George Bush's son
George W Bush and has done investments
for Lloyd Bentsen and was in business
with Lloyd Bentsen son and bath of
course ties in with Michigan got loans
from issuers bank and it's all a very
tight little circle here that the Bush
and Benson are two peas in a pod as far
as being controlled and dealing with and
a friendship with the same people and
what about any other connections that
Benson might have to the SNL crisis
other than him owning this one SNL for
20 years did he have investments in our
connections with other SNL's who were
involved in the crisis or did he do
things as a senator that might be
involved in making sure there's no
investigations etc well I don't know if
he ever directly intervened but he
certainly didn't push for it and he was
head of the Senate Finance Committee
that could have done all sorts of
investigations he never did I mean in
fact he did his best to see that the
crisis was not brought up he had three
savings and loans at one time it all
ended up in the hands of either the
Mafia the CIA people Jefferson savings
went to Cartaya Continental savings went
to Carol Kelly was financed completely
by Herman KBD
and Ben Franklin say these later ended
up in the hands of Walter Mischer now
that this in and of itself is absolutely
incredible
that SNL's or banks or any institution
can be sold to mafia controlled groups
how is this even possible well it's
possible because the people in power
either don't know or don't want to know
that these are mafia people in louisvil
you know the Justice Department had not
done the kind of investigation required
the Federal Home Loan Bank board wasn't
doing investigations and the press was
not reporting of course everybody knew
who BB was from the Dallas Morning News
wrote about BB in the texas random acts
scandal but seemed to forget about it
you know ten years later when they're
back involved in SNL's and no one you
know raised plummet when you've got
Congress not doing anything we got the
Justice Department not anything we got
the press not do anything that the
public is not going to find out and
nobody's going to know and what did
Benson say that he didn't know that
these were mafia connections that he
just sold his interests and someone
bought them and he didn't investigate
well I think he knew who you selling to
but he he could say we didn't know the
money was coming from the Mafia well
that's you know that's the kind of
ignorance we don't need if indeed he
didn't know I mean it's an ignorance
that's almost criminal I mean if it's
not if it's not you didn't do anything
criminal by actual knowing and intending
that it happened his ignorance borders
on recklessness people we have a lot of
more questions for you and we're out of
time for this program but would you like
to continue on and do a second program
we want to get into how you got this
story and incredible information that
you got and then wove together and the
problems you had and
getting stories printed and also getting
the book published we would you would
you stay here and do us the favor of
that sir great welcome to the second
part of our alternative views interview
with author Pete Bruton Pete is just
published a book called the Mafia CIA
and George Bush and on our last program
we told how P analyzed the connection
between the CIA and the S&L fraud and
how he discovered that George Bush and
his family unsavory folks connected to
the CIA and the Mafia as well as
associates of Texas bigshots such as
senator Lloyd Bentsen and Houston power
broker Walter Mischer were all involved
in the SNL fraud which was one of the
greatest u.s. financial catastrophes and
crimes in our history today
however we're going to talk about how
Pete came to break the story about his
experiences as a Houston Post reporter
in which he discovered the connections
between the SNL and the CIA scandal how
he decided to write a book his
experiences with Simon & Schuster and
how he finally got his book published
and what the response of the book by the
media has been you've been tracking this
SNL thing for a long time what is the
magnitude of the scandal well we we all
hear about is going to cost taxpayers
about five hundred billion dollars that
includes a little over two hundred
billion of actual losses that the SNL's
have incurred that failed that the
taxpayer is going to have to pay back
but when you throw in interest in
carrying costs you get over five hundred
billion dollars in direct cost that the
other costs are almost as bad what these
fraudulent SNL's did was create an
artificial real estate bubble where they
inflated real estate values artificially
very much and then the bubble burst and
that sort of spread out that the fallout
from that spread to the banks and
insurance companies and any other
financial institutions that were lending
on real estate and so one of the reasons
the banks are in big trouble now is
their real estate portfolio and the
larger 8a such a portfolio Bank is the
more trouble it's in so that the effect
spread out through the economy in the
real estate value so it's not just five
hundred billion which is an incredible
hit but also the indirect real estate
effects I guess also you could crank
into this the amount of money that was
skimmed and stolen by all these people
was money which did not go into
productive resources so that we're
losing out from that aspect also
absolutely I mean when you think about
somebody is estimated that the actual
cost when we start paying back to
tonight's mayor is going to be twenty
five billion dollars a year from now on
forever if you think about what twenty
five billion dollars every year what we
could have used for that and then when
you think about the money was basically
looted and stolen and that Congress and
Justice Department are not trying to get
it back and that's one of the keys to
all this is tracing the money and also
trying to recover it there's been none
of that I mean Congress doesn't want to
do it because they're involved up to
their eyeballs we start tracing this
money like you did with the Keating five
you find it comes in somewhere it comes
back to their own campaign in the chest
and the Justice Department which is
controlled by the the president of
course has not tried to track the money
they're interested in just getting the
frontman and the cutouts in the middle
into guilty pleas and go to jail maybe
for a year or two and then go on to the
next one so they rack up all these
convictions but they don't try to really
figure out what happened and where the
money went who benefited one of the
reasons why the government has not done
any real prosecution or investigation of
this scandal is because they've been
involved in it going all the way to the
top up to George Bush we didn't really
get into last time the complicity of
George Bush's son Neal in a SNL scandal
the Silverado case perhaps we can go
into that as an illustration of how the
SNL
gondol word and the complicity of top
establishment officials in this crisis
sure we all know that Neal was a
director of Silverado savings in Denver
Colorado and that when he was on the
board of directors he was being
supported financially by a couple of
Denver businessmen named Kim good and
Bill Walters at the same time Walters
and good were borrowing huge amounts of
money from Silverado and in fact Neal
got his hand slapped in administrative
action for approving loans to his
business associate bill Walters what we
don't know what hasn't come out really
before or the connections between not
only good and Walters but to other
silverado borrowers to mafia people and
to the CIA and we find that if you look
at Bill Walters bill Walters was the
largest borrower at several auto savings
he signed on about a hundred thirty
million dollars of loans in addition he
sold property to silver out of about
ninety million dollars
Walters was a Denver architect Walters
and his partners including a guy named
Richard Ross Miller were involved in the
Texas Renta bank scandal back in the
mid-70s with Herman KBB I mean Dede was
in bed Barnes were involved and deals
with these people and BB specifically
had transferred about a million dollars
to Richard Ross Miller built their
Walters partner and they had all owned a
bank in Marshall Texas that was involved
in the Texas Renta bank scandal and we
found that Walters was also apparently
and had been accused of transferring
some of his ill-gotten gains to a trust
on the Isle of Jersey that was being
funneled drug money was being laundered
through it by people in Miami and SNL
money from people like Robert Corson the
CIA agent was going also going through
this trust fund Ken good who barred over
40 million dollars from Silverado and
was Neil Bush his sugar daddy for
several years had also barred money from
Western savings and down
it was part of the Herman KBB circle the
biggest company that actually dealt with
Silverado was MDC Holdings it was whose
chief executive is Larry my cell my cell
was a big Republican donor he held
fundraisers that George Bush went to and
Mizell had established trust funds by
gun by a Chicago law firm whose partner
was Burton Kanter Burton Kanter was one
of the founding fathers of castle bank
and trust the bank and the Bahamas that
the Mafia and the CIA were using he was
involved with CIA projects mafia
projects in California and other mafia
figures and here we have his trust you
know Larry Meisels trust fund being set
up by Burton Cantor's law firm and
Burton Cantor was also a close associate
of Lawrence Freeman the Miami lawyer who
had worked for Paul Helliwell the CIA
founding father and works for the Mafia
and had been involved in the big florida
land deal that robert Corson's S&L was
funding we find this circle you start
pulling on this thread you look at the
people involved and still write on your
back with the Mafia the CIA now how did
Neil Bush get involved in all of this
what was his initial connection with
Silverado what did he get out of it Neil
Bush had gone to Denver after getting
out of college and was a land man for
Amoco I believe was me and he went tried
to secure leases so they could drill on
the land and then Bill Walters and Ken
good set him up in his own company okay
they were both big Republican donor a
kid good went to the inauguration party
with Neil Bush in Houston in 1988 when
Bush won Bush visited bill Walters home
in the 1984 campaign Bill Walters tore
up all his brown grass and laid new
green grass on his lawn just for George
Bush's visit we can
they were pumping money into neo Bush's
company there was drilling dry holes in
Wyoming was not making any money he was
being basically salary of being paid by
these people and his company got a big
line of credit at Bill Walters Bank so
they were supporting him Ken good put
him on the board of directors of a
Florida company head was paying him over
$100,000 a year in directors fees
outrageous twelve million dollars I mean
$12,000 a month was going to Neil Bush
for just serving on ken goods board they
were basically keeping him going and he
held protection money it sounds like
well you know it's almost somebody made
the analogy that Neil Bush was sort of
like the driver of the getaway car and
you know the cops weren't going to shoot
at the president's son
and so far all we've had is one
indictment the the CEO Michael Weis is
the only indictment so far on Silverado
savings now what about Neil Bush and
Silverado
what role did he play well he was in
particular a director and he approved
loans to his buddy bill Walters he also
approved loans to the second largest
borrower at Silverado was a Houston con
man they meet Ron Starnes storage bar at
77 1/2 million dollars from Silverado
six months after he donated $30,000 to
the Contras and when it had a meeting
with Ronald Reagan and Oliver North
and he also borrowed over 25 million
dollars from Continental savings in
Houston that was supported by mafia
money from Herman KBB and Starnes was
also involved with John Whittle the guy
who was transshipping arms to the Middle
East and had had gotten support from
allied bank Walter Mishra's bank and he
turns out to be the second largest
borrower at Silverado savings so Neil
Bush was was basically just sitting on
the board almost like a figurehead but
approving these loans and you know
helping his buddies out and Jane paid
also for it as a dryer
that's correct although not nearly as
much as he got from from being a
director I'm kidding
company let's talk about how you got
this incredible story now your book is
to me a masterpiece in the sense that
everything is so complex there's so many
interconnections and so many layers of
activity and yet you were able to lay it
out so that it it makes sense and you
can follow it my first question is how
did you get all this voluminous material
and keep track of it well I've been
working on for over five years I mean
anybody can probably collect that much
information in five years you know you
I've got three four-drawer file cabinets
full of documents that support all this
information but I mean you just take one
step at a time and when I first started
on the SNL story in the spring of 87 and
looking at one deal at Mainland savings
in Houston when it failed in 86 was the
largest failure in the country and you
start running into roadblocks and people
not talking you can't get documents and
nobody is being prosecuted the money
hadn't been tracked and nobody's trying
to get the money back dan you start
saying something dig is going on here
and you start pushing I mean if we had
run into the roadblocks we might have
stopped with that first story but when
you start running it everywhere people
covering up the government not doing
anything
nobody's seeming to care where are these
billions of dollars went our care to try
to get them back that's when you start
looking for you you know you know you've
got a big story and so you just keep
going I mean everywhere I looked I found
something it was like I mean being in
the old business everywhere you dig a
hole you hit oil I mean every rock you
turn over something scurries out from
under it and it's just it was a
wonderful story in that sense well you
have I mean divorce decrees were
significant thank you like this yeah
well you know that the SNL's do not the
documents that the S nails are not
public the loan documents where the
money went the closing documents the
public can get and reporters cannot get
them we cannot track the money we don't
have subpoena power so the things you
rely on are lawsuits and deed records
basically and so the divorce decrees are
in divorce lawsuits are very they have a
lot of good information in them let's go
into the history of how you actually
came to write this book starting with
your first stories with the Houston post
in the spring of 86 I was working on
stories involving charitable foundations
and hospitals that were not doing enough
services for the poor and a business
report at the post named Greg C got an
anonymous call from a guy that we had we
dealt with for over two years and we his
nickname was DT which was you know a
shark for deep throat and for a long
time we didn't even know who he was well
this guy calls up Greg and tells him he
should start investigating mainland
Savings and there its deals with a man
named Howard Pulver so Greg starts doing
this and we eventually found out at
Pulver and his partners had over 300
companies and they were doing deals with
mainland all over Houston and Greg just
found himself drowning in a sea of
records there were thousands and
thousands of pages of records in the the
real property records of Harris County
on these deals with mainland so I was
asked just to come help him sort out the
records and we did that and then we went
and interviewed Raymond Hill the chief
executive officer of mainland savings
and Hills attitude was was the most
arrogant that I've ever encountered in
my career as a reporter and basically he
accused us at one point of stumbling in
the same direction as the FBI and I knew
I had a big story just the way he was
acting like we can't touch him and and
sort of really thumbing his nose at us
that I knew that there was a big story
there and and we immediately ran into
the Mafia
there was a when we were trying to track
the deal with with Howard Palmer who
lived in Kings Point Long Island outside
New York and his partners were off in
New York City that came down it took
close to 100 million dollars out of
mainland cities left them with with
promissory notes that were worth you
know probably less than 10 million
dollars a huge ripoff and contributed
greatly to the failure of mainland
savings at the same time he was doing
this mario Rinda was brokering money
into mainland in fact there was an
indictment in brooklyn by the organized
crime strike force talking about the
money
mario Renda was skimming off of his
deposits and placing in various SNL's
and one of them was mainland so we knew
we had something maybe went up to New
York City and we found rendus partner
this was a guy named Martin Schwimmer
who was also laundering money for the
Lucchese Mafia family okay when we went
to talked to Howard Pulver and the
markzware we found they lived across the
street from each other in Kings Point
New York which is a very wealthy
suburban Enclave on the North Shore of
Long Island very exclusive and so here
we had Schwimmer pumping maybe a hundred
million dollars in deposits in the
mainland and the guy lives across the
street women taking about a hundred
million dollars out the back door and so
we knew he had something very big then
and then when he found we started
tracking Rendon and then we heard about
Herman KBB Louisiana mafia associate who
was involved in all the failed Texas s
Mills we started tracking BB and then we
find BB and Renda together it's so many
different plate here's a New York Mafia
associate in a Louisiana mafia associate
both at the same places the same times
across the country so we know we knew
that there was a big big story here who
are you shocked or surprised to see that
the Mafia was active in looting these
sno banks in Texas or had you studied
organized crime before
just on a couple of occasions we've run
into every that the myth is there's no
organized crime in Texas and it's it's
it's wrong it's just flat wrong they're
out there a couple of small indigenous
Mafia families in Texas been a big mafia
family but it Texas is basically under
the aegis of the Louisiana
Macross Marcelo Mafia family and there's
there's a lots of mafia activity in
Texas I mean of course any time you have
you know people like the old Texas
oilman that naturally like to gamble I
mean the way the Mafia gets their their
foot in the door and their fingers into
a community new communities through
gambling I mean that's the way to do it
and of course all men naturally love
anybody likes to Gamble's got all that
money I mean they're going to have to if
you bet big on anything illegally you're
dealing with the Mafia probably where
you know it or not and if you don't pay
up you're going to find out in a hurry
there's a question yeah and and that we
found that if you look at all the the
congressional crime committees and in
there studying of course Marcel you find
in one case where he was talking to a
Houston bald man named Josie in one case
and and we find John Meachem jr. the
Houston or man dealing with the
Marcelo's so it means you find them in
Texas and dealing with a lot of the big
wheeler dealers and power brokers the
story was this was running in the
Houston post but I've noticed in
studying local power structures in the
media that the usually the local media
don't take on or expose any of the
activities of local power brokers but
you were writing about Mischer well I
was writing about him but none of the
stories on Mishra running until all this
over century yeah when we had done we
spent two years working on the Mafia and
then we fell
that about the CIA and I spent another
year working on the CIA and that's when
I ran into Misha
former son-in-law Robert Corson and then
all the connections when I started
looking at Mischer the connections of
measure to the SNL players and that took
me about a year to do and in the fall of
1989 we were ready to run with the CIA
SNL stories and Walter measure of course
was the center in the center of it and
and he his story the story that he'll
was scheduled to lead it off I mean
because he's the glue that holds all
this together and it's very difficult to
understand the story without Walter
wisher now there may be somebody above
measure telling him what to do and I was
told by a couple of people in Houston
that there is indeed but I was never
able to identify that person if indeed
that person exists but Miz sure was is
the key middleman the key broker of all
the deals and with that end it's very
difficult to understand these stories
the stories were scheduled to run in the
the winter of 1989 we sent them over to
the Houston post law firm Fulbright &
Jaworski to read for libel they sort of
read all the stories for libel and try
to give us advice usually they they had
the authority although they shouldn't
have to kill stories that they thought
might get us in the liable trouble well
Fulbright & Jaworski went through the
ceiling on mission they immediately
reacted that we can't run this stuff and
gave a lot of bogus reasons for not
doing so so we began in the in February
of 1990 to run the CIA stories but
nothing on Mischer we had Corson we had
a Kansas City guy named Farhad Azima
we had a little savings alone Atlanta
called people's that was was lending
money to CIA people in Florida we had
silverado savings in San Jacinto we ran
all these these stories but nothing on
mission and
we ran out of stories eventually in the
summer of 1990 it must been difficult to
write your story with the main actor not
being able very difficult and and most
of the national media reacted negatively
I mean they they did not pick up the
story they said you know they it was too
hard to understand a lot of other
reasons I think and also the Houston
post is to blame for what they were not
running a big series they would just
have one story and wait several weeks
and run another one and wait and I think
it's just because they were afraid of
the story and they were afraid you know
they just kind of wanted to stick the
little foot in the water and see if it
got bit off and then run another one if
it didn't and so they were they were
released sporadic ly and there was no
measure in it so a lot of the national
media does not pick up I don't know if
it run them as a series and had measured
whether they had any more impact it's
difficult to tell the national media
really handles the CIA with kid gloves
and we can talk about that later
why if you'd like to but anyway we've
run out of stories so I went back to the
Mischer stuff I tried to get that in
again and the editors signed off on it
they approved it I thought I'd met all
of Fulbright & Jaworski objections they
were scheduled to run in the last of
December of 1990 and then at the very
last moment for Ron Jaworski refused to
sign off on the stories the editors even
though the city editor wanted to run
them and and really recommended running
them over for Roger skis and objections
the editor in chief decided not to do it
not through the mystery stories now
during this period I was talking I was
at my folks ranch it was Christmas time
I was talking to the city editor and the
for Brian Jaworski associate that was
handling the mr. Styles got any tom god
bold and I was talking on the front of
the city as you said God Baal won't sign
and and I was I was furious and I said
he's jobs probably on the line I bet he
won't get made partner if he doesn't
kill these stories you know I was just
just talking I was mad well six weeks
later I'd taken leave of absence to
write work on the book and I had lunch
with the city editor and he looked at he
said guess what God Bo just got made
partner and that's a little bright and
be norske so that's when I started
looking for conflicts of interest now a
year and a half earlier when God Bo was
objecting to all the mission stuff I
directly asked him do you have any just
foreground rescue have any conflicts of
interest with these stories and he said
not that I know of okay when I found
close to a dozen conflicts of interest
including the ferry full runs were ski
was representing mistress company in a
wrongful death lawsuit at the same time
they were telling us we couldn't run
these stories about Walter Mission in
addition they were also doing other
things from Mischer as well as doing
legal things for Palmer National Bank
this bank in Washington DC
they had represent Howard Pulver's
company in an insurance deal and on they
had laundered money for a for the CIA
basically through the MD Anderson
foundation and conflict after conflict I
dug on for Ron Jaworski now I went to
the Houston post I told them about these
conflicts and the Houston post did
nothing and so I knew that then I could
not go to back back to work for the
Houston post if I'm going to have to run
everything through Fulbright & Jaworski
he was serving as the ultimate editors
and all these stories so was it at this
time you decided to go the book route
that you'd resigned from the Houston
post and try to write this up as a book
well actually it had happened earlier
during the middle of the stories I were
writing for the the post in the summer
of 1990 Simon & Schuster came to me
actually approached me with an idea of
writing a book for them Simon Schuster
is either the first or second largest
publishing company
a country in this company in this
country and very prestigious and they
flew me up to New York City rolled out
the red carpet and made me a very big
offer to write the book for them hundred
thousand eight hundred thousand dollar
advance which is probably bigger than
any advance on a savings and loan book
it has been been written and so we began
negotiating a contract and I was
insistent in the beginning at the very
beginning that the book be published
before the 1992 presidential election
when this isn't by the way to summer of
1990 and because not only because of
what I found on George Bush but what I
found on Lloyd Bentsen and at that time
it certainly wasn't beyond the realm of
possibility that the 92 election was
going to be Bush versus Benson and in
fact if you recall when Clinton had all
the trouble and earlier this year with
in january/february ennifer flowers and
the draft he said that if he dropped out
he was going to throw his support behind
Lloyd Bentsen and now we have Benson
being the leading candidate for the
Secretary of Treasury okay so I was
pushing very hard and for Bryan's work
ski actually modified their standard
contract to shorten the time between
acceptance and publication insider new
Simon Schuster I'm sorry to short the
time between acceptance and publication
and I eventually signed a contract with
am in and when I took a leave of absence
from the post to write the book I
submitted the book on deadline and I got
back an editing letter a couple of
months after that that totally was
something wasn't exactly right here
because they wrote me a four-page letter
that was just full of diagonal cents and
he was not helpful at all and when I
submitted the manuscript on deadline I
again put in writing that the book had
to be published before the 1992 election
in writing so we begin the editing
process and I tried to accommodate their
suggestions and I really
couldn't I made some alternative
suggestions they okayed it I submitted a
revised manuscript in February of this
year in 92 and after they got the
revised manuscript but before they'd
even read it they really cut me off they
would not return my phone calls my faxes
my letters nothing
and so I was fairly desperate at that
time and I knew that they had what they
call their fall list the list law books
they published in the latter part of the
year and I knew that my book had to be
on there to get out before the election
and so when they wouldn't return my
phone calls or talk to me I eventually
made an appointment just to fly up to
New York City and see them and if that
was that only at that time that they
that they returned my phone call and I
told the editor who was Alice Mayhew who
was Bob Woodward's and a very famous
editor you know that the book needed to
go before the election we needed to get
going and she said she wasn't going to
do that we're not going to do the book
before the election and I said why not
you know all this stuff about boosting
American public needs to know and she
said quote George Bush is going to win
anyway and she turned out to be wrong
but even so it struck me as non-family
what difference does that make about
getting getting the information before
the public and in what how does she know
that what's going to happen in it was
again in ten months or so but why do you
think Simon & Schuster refused to
publish the book before the election was
ready to go right well as it was
basically ready and if they wanted to
they could have he was not me stylish
hughster is a very big company I mean I
eventually got the book published before
the election with a small company I mean
they could have put two editors on it
and we could have done it they didn't I
don't know I mean I don't want to
speculate on their motives but there's
some interesting connections in fact I
knew this going in I knew about the
connections between Simon & Schuster and
George Bush and the Houston power broker
Oh what is that well when a george
bush's best friends and longtime
business associates hewlett key chair
labora depends oil is on the board of
directors of Simon & Schuster's parent
corporation paramount communications &
hué Lake he's actually in my book in
regard to a very strange bank in Houston
that he was on the board up also
paramount communications used to be is
the successor company to Gulf and
Western the conglomerate that were one
of the founding fathers is John Duncan
of Houston whose brother Charles was
Secretary of Energy under the Carter
Administration and these people are in
investments with people who connect to
Walter mission and and back to George
Bush and so I knew this going in I just
thought it'd be poetic justice for
silence you stir to publish this book
you know but apparently they knew about
it too I guess
Pete you've been you've been dealing
with some pretty unsavory and dangerous
characters here the CIA and the Mafia
have you had any threats on your life or
you been fearful of it well I'm not that
I know
you know kind of slow maybe I got
threatened I didn't realize it but
nothing directly I mean that these
people usually leave reporters and late
on you know threatened reporters I mean
they may try to keep the book from being
published or they might threaten you and
even I've been threatened with lawsuits
oh I mean they will do that but not
physically threatened and you know they
the way they operate is to keep people
like Simon Schuster from publishing the
book or keep anybody from posting or
keeping it from being distributed and so
you know they work indirectly not now I
mean if anything happened to me that
would just bring more publicity on this
and which is the last thing they want I
mean that the way they're reacting to
the book is that they're really sort of
kind of hunkering down and ignoring it
and figuring that any publicity will
will
will vanish eventually and disappear
have you been contacted by Larry King
yet or any of them know the national
media show no interest in this the only
one exception is the Village Voice that
published day excellent the article on
your book and on your research by
Jonathon Whitney who is also an
investigative reporter of some renowned
write that happened when scientists used
her told me they were not going to
publish before the election
I contacted kwitny I had been in touch
with Jonathan Whitney because he'd
written a number of books on the site on
the Mafia and the CIA and you know I
wanted to sort of do a reality check and
send the manuscript acquit me and ask
him whether he thought it should be
published before the election just to
make sure that I wasn't hallucinating
maybe Simon Schuster was right and so I
sent the manuscript too quickly
and he read it and agreed with me that
it should be published before the
election and he was helping me you know
get the information out and that
actually was what had gone to a number
of different publications to try to do
you know a serialization of the book and
eventually those boys did it but just
barely before the election and even
though the book was printed four weeks
before the election it really didn't get
out I mean it should have been out in
the summer and I really apologize I did
everything that I didn't have and if so
you told somebody and say May of this
year that you could get a book published
in five months they would have laughed
at you so it was not possible well we
did it but just barely
Pete let's talk a little bit about the
sort of final response of your work by
the establishment by journalists
Congress and then possibly the public
and how you reacted to the sort of non
response of the sort of journalists
establishment and then the Congress you
yourself was a reporter for the human
Houston post you published these
articles about the CIA
and the SNL's were explosive
investigative reporting and they just
weren't picked up by the national media
what did this lead you to conclude
towards the press in the United States
well just change your attitude anyway
well I mean some of the press picked up
stories but the the television networks
and the big three the New York Times The
Washington Post The Wall Street Journal
never did anything and I personally
think the reason they didn't was because
it wasn't their story okay and they like
to do their own investigative work and
they were very far behind it would have
been impossible for them to do the work
it would take to do these stories in a
manner that would you know there would
be a good job and these these
institutions had not even done the S&L
stories right I mean they had ignore
basically nor have done a little bit but
it was all that they were just recycling
the work that had basically been done by
the Dallas Morning News and Byron Harris
WFAA in Dallas which was to write about
all the wheeler-dealer Don Dixon ed
McBurney types and that began to be sort
of the pattern of investigative
reporting if you did investigate
reporting on SNL's you rat wrote about
all the while and crazy guys down at
Texas that were looting this these SNL's
and you didn't do what you should have
done which was follow the money but
that's the big advice you know deep
throat gave Bob Woodward in Watergate
follow the money that's where the that's
where the story is that's where the
story is in the SNL's that the reporters
did not do that it was right about the
front men a while and crazy guys so
these institutions did not do a very
good job on the SNL's so they didn't
have the foundation to do either the
Mafia or the CIA involvement so you know
if if you don't do something they're the
kind of institutions of people that just
ignore it you know it's not our story
it's not worth doing we're just going to
ignore it you know if we didn't do it it
must not be worth anything so that's
luckily what happened now what about
Congress when you first made these
revelations that the CIA was involved in
robbing the CIA the savings and loan and
using the money to help support the
Contras and other illegal off-the-book
operations Congress made some noise that
they were going to do some investigation
what came out of this well actually the
house permanent Subcommittee on
intelligence which has oversight of CIA
did a preliminary investigation by their
staff and it eventually came up and said
there's nothing to this but it's
interest there's several interesting
points to note number one they never did
what they should have done which was
tracking the money they relied on the
CIA for all their information and even
the CIA admitted that of the like the 20
institutions we named that they had
dealt with for them and that they had
dealt with five of the individuals we'd
known but they had done nothing wrong
and the thing is that the staff director
of the House Intelligence Committee who
was overseeing the investigation guy
named dan childs had come from the sea
was the the chief financial officer of
the CIA and had been brought over to the
intelligence subcommittee right before
my stories came out and the CIA of
course was aware the I had been talking
to them for months so they knew that my
stories were going to break soon dan
childs also had been brought in ten
years earlier in the Senate Intelligence
Committee that had been doing the church
investigation was exposing all the
illegal domestic activities of CIA
childs had been brought in for damage
control it certainly looked like he was
being brought in for damage control and
in fact after they released their report
saying there was nothing to this child's
went back to see now he's the executive
assistant to the CIA director this is
shameless it's like this guy
who was put in charge of investigating
iran-contra who is another lifetime CIA
operatives station chief about six
different places as you point out in
your book so basically Congress didn't
do anything
no they covered it up the press really
didn't do anything
and now the Clinton administration faces
as much as a five hundred billion dollar
price tag for the CIA a scandal so what
can the government finally do about this
Congress and the Justice Department can
track the money that's all they have to
do it if there was fraud involved they
can get it back and they haven't done
this I mean everybody's acting like it's
a foregone conclusion that we've lost
five hundred billion dollars you know
okay taxpayers take the hit and go on
it's not true the Justice Department is
very capable of tracking this money they
can track drug money it starts out as
cash in United States goes offshore and
comes back surely they can track S&L
money it's always a paper or wire
transfer it's easy to track if you got
subpoena power Congress could do it but
they're not doing it and I don't know
whether Clinton is going to make the
Justice Department do this or not
you know where it's going to be
interesting a new Attorney General is
going to be and whether they're going to
go out I mean I don't see any indication
of Clinton's part that he has any
interest in kicking this sleeping dog
and I think he just wants to let it lie
and not mess with it because his party
is just as involved as a Republicans and
so I don't see there's going to have to
take just be masse revoked by the
American people and American people
don't have the information so what is
the responsibility of the press and the
citizens to do something about this S&L
scandal well I mean the press has got to
do the reporting and the citizens have
to do the complaining